بعد ساعات من وقوع الزلزال خرجت السلطات
في تركيا وفي سوريا بنداءات وخطوات عاجله
مع اولويه واحده انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه في
تركيا اعلنت الحكومه حاله الانذار على
المستوى الرابع وهذا يعني عمليا ان البلاد
تطالب المساعده من الاخرين وبالفعل هب
المنقذون من دول العالم باسره في سوريا
الوضع اكثر تعقيدا فالارض مقسمه في الشمال
بين مناطق سيطره النظام ومناطق سيطره
المعارضه وقلت تلك المناطق التقت في
النكبه دمشق ناشد الدول العالم لمساعدتها
واول المستجبين دول عربيه وحلفاء دمشق في
دول مثل روسيا اما مناطق سيطره المعارضه
فقد اعلنت جهات اضافيه فيها انها مناطق
منكوبه بشكل كامل بسبب سقوط عشرات الضحايا
فيما لم يتضح بعد اي خطط لانقاذ المتضررين
[موسيقى]